Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Birçok kere sunuma gittim,
birçok yerleri gezdim,
ama bugün burada olmak beni
gerçekten çok heyecanlandırıyor,
çünkü ben Adanalıyım.
Adana'nın Çelemli köyünde doğdum.
Mersin Arslanköy'ün geliniyim.
Bir kere, köyde doğdum,
köyde büyüdüm, köyde yaşıyorum.
Köylü olmaktan gurur duyuyorum.
(Alkış)
Şimdi, kurban olduklarım.
Ben on kardeşin altıncısı
olarak dünyaya geldim.
Her zaman ben dokuz kardeş derdim,
anam da derdi ki, "Olur mu öyle şey,
ben on tane doğum yaptım."
Birisi üç aylıkken ölmüştü çünkü.
Ben onu bilmediğim için
hep dokuz kardeş derdim,
ama on kardeşiz ve ben altıncısıyım.
Benim köyümde,
kız çocukları o zamanlar okula gitmezdi,
çünkü âdetti.
Hani, âdet yoktu.
Yokluktan falan değil.
Gönderilmezdi, ayıptı, dedikodu olurdu.
Kız çocukları okula gitmez, çalışmaz;
evin içinde, sadece evin işini
yapar işte hanımının, eşinin.
Hani, evin dışına çıkmazdı.
Ama bir gün ben, 7-8 yaşları arasındayken,
camiden bir anons edildi.
Denildi ki,
''Her evden bir kız çocuğu okula gidecek,
eğer gönderilmezse,
baba ya da anne hapse atılacak.''
Ben bir sevindim ama!
Çünkü ben gideceğim, sonradan tabii
hemen yelkenler suya düştü,
benden küçük vardı.
Onu gönderdiler, o da gitmedi.
Babam düşünüyor artık,
birinden biri hapse gidecek.
Velhasıl çok uzatmayayım, süremiz kısa
ben bunları anlatırsam haftalar sürer.
Tesadüfen ilkokulu bitirdim
kız kardeşim gidemeyince.
Ama, ilkokul 3. sınıfa giderken, evimiz,
çok şanslıydım, evimiz okula yakındı
ve küçük lojmanlar vardı, öğretmenlerle
ablamlar haşır neşir olduğu için,
beni de çok severdiler.
Öğretmenim bana bir gün dedi ki,
Yıldız, soy ismim Yıldız olduğu için,
Yıldız git benim odadan kitabı getir
bana dedi, kitabımı getir
o da masanın üstünde, dedi.
Ben o kitabı aldım, şöyle bir baktım.
Üstünde kırışık yüzlü,
aynı anam gibi bir resim var.
Allah allah, yabancı da adı,
ama şöyle bir araladım, baktım baktım.
Allah allah, bizim köyü anlatıyor sanki.
Baktım evin içinde sobası var,
aynı köyü anlatıyor,
ben onu o an kısa bir süreylen,
hemen hayal kurdum, yanımdaki
arkadaşımların isimlerini koydum,
erkeklerin ismini erkek arkadaşlarım
koydum sınıftan, ilkokul 3. sınıftaydım.
Ve o kısacık mesafede,
kitabın aralarından okumamla birlikte,
ben taa nereleri gezdim ve o kitabın adı,
Maksim Gorki'nin ''Ana'' kitabıydı.
Ben hayal kurdum,
(Alkış)
çünkü o küçücük yerde,
ben kendimle özdeşleştirdim.
Çünkü o, o köydeydi, yani hayal kuruyordu.
E bunun o zaman ben, ilkokulu bitirdikten
sonra okumayacağım, bunun bilincindeydim,
ne olabilirdim; en beleşi hayal kurmaktı,
bunun peşinden gitmekti.
Ben de onu yaptım
ve yılmadım, bıkmadan, hep okudum, okudum,
hep okuyorum, hâlâ da okuyacağım.
Ve üretmeyi, başarmayı,
çalışmayı çok seviyorum.
Çünkü taa çocuklukluğumdan beri;
benim öyle çok oyuncaklarım oldu, lüks bir
hayat yaşadım dersem, yalan söylerim.
Hep yaratıcılığımı geliştirdim.
Oyuncağım olmadı, süpürgeden bebek yaptım.
Çamurdan bebekler, tencereler yaptım.
Büyüklerim pekmez kaynatırken,
herkesi organize ettim,
onlarla birlikte ben de pekmez kaynattım.
Ve evlendim, Mersin'in Arslanköyüne
gelin geldim, 19 yaşlarındayım.
Ve kurban olduklarım,
baktım,
çünkü iyi bir dinleyiciyim,
iyi bir gözlemciyim
ve hepsini bir araya getirince de,
ben biraz bunaldım, boğuldum,
çünkü benim köyümde kadınlar hiç işe
gitmiyordu, ama gelin geldiğim köyde;
erkekler oturuyordu, kadınlar çalışıyordu.
Ben bir şeyler yapmalıyım, dedim
ve oradaki kızlar liseyi bitirince
hiçbir şey yapamıyordu,
çocuk bakıcılığını başlattım memurların,
öğretmenlerin çocuklarına vesaire.
Temizliğe gitmeye başladım,
vesaire vesaire çok uzun.
Ama bunlar bana da yetmedi, çünkü kim
çocuk bakmaya başladıysa ben onu bıraktım.
Temizliğe başladım, temizliğe gitmeye
başladılarsa onu da bıraktım.
Ve en sonunda dedim ki,
Ümmiye kızım, sen, öyle bir şey
yapmalısın ki bu Arslanköyde,
çünkü benim köyümde,
yaşadığım yerdeki köyde her bir tarafı
Güney Toros Dağları ile çevrili.
Ben, buradaki yaşayan kadınların sesini,
Mersin'e duyurmalıyım, bakın Mersin'e
diyorum çünkü, ağzımdan Mersin
çıkıyor ama yüreğim de diyor ki,
sen böyle gidersen bütün
dünyaya duyurursun,
ama ben sadece Mersin'i istedim.
Tek hedefim Mersin'di.
Ne yapabilirim, araştırması içindeyken,
köyüme tiyatro grubu geldi.
Öne oturdum şalvarımlan, dedim ki,
bitti çıktım çocukların yanına,
''Kurban olduğum senin adın ne,'' dedim.
Ali, dedi.
E ama demin Veli idi, dedim.
Olur mu teyze, dedi.
O benim rol adım, dedi.
Ben o gece sabaha kadar, hiç uyumadan,
Ayşe'nin anlattığını,
Fatma'nın anlattığını,
çünkü köyde iyi bir dinleyici olduğum için
bana gelip her şeyi anlatıyor herkes,
ama utanıyor anlatırken, kocasından
gördüğünü, kaynanasından gördüğünü,
kocasından gördüğü şiddetleri,
başkasınınmış gibi anlatıyor.
Oysa ben biliyorum, olanları biliyorum.
Haa Ümmiye kızım, dedim kendi kendime.
O zaman ben de bunların isimlerini
değiştirip bunların yaşadıklarını
bunlara seyrettirirsem,
o zaman bunlar yanlışlarını görür,
o zaman köydeki erkekler de
kendilerini değiştirirler, dedim.
Ve dediğimi de yapacağım,
ama nasıl olacak öyle hiç kolay değil.
Velhasıl, hiç kolay da olmadı.
Sonucunda 40 kapıya gittim.
O yedi bayanı bulmak için.
Sonuç itibariyle buldum da,
ha bana yanlış kelimeler kullanırdı;
sana mı kaldı, öyle miydi, böyle miydi.
Ben onlara hep teşekkür ettim,
yine de teşekkür ediyorum,
çünkü onların bana hep yanlış yapması,
sırtımdan beni kamçıladı,
ilerlememe neden oldu.
Onlara teşekkür ederim.
Ve tiyatroyu kurdum artık.
Ve basından herkes gelmeye başladı.
Ama şunu anlatmadan geçemeyeceğim.
Köydeyiz, hiç tiyatrodan
kimsenin haberi yok.
Şimdi benim aklıma geldi,
gittim biraz tahsilli olana.
Dedim, böyle böyle
bir tiyatro kuracağım ama,
en akıllıları benim, nasıl olacak
ben de bilmiyorum sen yardım et.
Dedi ki, olur mu öyle dedi, ben yapamam
ben tuhafiye işletiyorum, dedi.
Sonra işte müdüre git dedi, müdüre gittim
bana Müjdat Gezen'in kitabını verdi.
Ben gündüz bağ bahçede çalıştım,
akşamları onu okudum.
Arkadaşlarıma gittim, yufka atıyoruz
biz imece usulü kışlık ekmeğimizi.
Kızlar dedim, gelin bir tiyatro
yapalım biz de, dedim.
O nedir kız, dedi.
Laf olur ne demekmiş o, dedi.
Olur mu kız, dedim.
Ümmiye abla ne demek o, dedi.
Biz ne hâl yapacağız onu, dedi.
Kız, dedim.
Sen dağdan odun getirmen mi?
''Hee, getirez.''
E bağ bahçede de çalışıyen.
''Çalışıyez.''
Evini ihmal eden mi?
''Yooo.''
Çocuğuna bakmiyen mi?
''Bakiyem.''
Peki sana, bu zamana kadar,
''Eline sağlık hanım,''
''Çok güzel olmuş gelin,''
diyen oldu mu?
''Yoo valla,'' dedi.
''Kimse demedi.''
E kız o zaman gelin, bunları ben
yazayım, sahnede oynayalım,
belki o zaman bize derler,
bizi takdir ederler, dedim.
Ümmiye abla, kız dedi.
Hakikaten ederler mi ki takdir, dedi.
Ederler, dedim.
Valla o zaman ben varım ama, dedi
bizim herifler ne diyecek dedi.
Ben, dedim, heriflerden izin alırım.
Gittim herifleri ikna ettim,
tiyatroyu kurduk ve geldiler, izlediler,
köy meydanında, kız Ümmiye abla
sanki beni yazmışın, dedi eşlerim.
Hâlbuki oydu zaten.
(Kahkaha)
Ama en çok hoşuma giden,
(Alkış)
şimdi o yanlışlar benim köyümde düzeldi,
hiç yok, artık kadın erkek
birlikte omuz omuza çalışıyor,
kesinlikle çınarın altında oturan yok.
Hedefime ulaşmıştım.
Ama bana bu da yetmiyordu.
Onun için, kadınların sesini
daha çok kitleye ulaştırmak için,
daha çok kitleye, çünkü bizim toplumumuzda
tiyatro diye bir şey yok maalesef.
Ben de dedim ki,
herkes televizyon izliyor maalesef,
biz bilinçli bir toplum olmadığımız için,
öyle bir şey yapmalıyım ki,
televizyonda izlenmeli, ama ne olmalı.
Çünkü 2005 yılında öyküsünü yazdığım
''Yün Bebek'' öyküsünü, tamamen
yaşlı teyzelerden dinleyerek yazmıştım.
70 yaşında, 75 yaşında teyzem bana
anlatırken çocukluğunu,
ağlayarak anlatmıştı.
Ben de kendi kendime dedim ki,
e bakın çocukluk çok önemli.
Biz çocuklarımıza ne verirsek onu alıyor,
çocuklarımıza biz yemedik, onlar yesin;
biz okuyamadık, onlar okusun diyerek
çok yanlış yapıyoruz
bilmeden anne baba olarak, dedim.
Ve bunun filmini çekmeliyim, dedim.
Çünkü bizim göz ardı ettiğimiz, herkesin
erkeğin kadına uyguladığı
şiddet için feryat figan ediyor.
Ben de diyorumkine;
hayır, kadında kadına şiddet
daha ön planda olmalı,
çünkü o çocukları biz yetiştiriyoruz,
biz onlara iyi örnek olmalıyız ki,
iyileri vermeliyiz ki onlar alsınlar.
Şimdi ben köyde yaşıyorum.
Malzeme o kadar bol ki,
hiç öyle hayal gücüne falan gerek yok.
Ayşe teyzemin evinin önünde sebzesi var,
berikinin de inekleri, koyunları var.
Her gün bahçeye giderken,
bir dal koparıyor hayvan,
bilmez ağzı var, dili yok.
O oradan bağırır edepli edepsiz, o oradan
kavga dövüş, ooh birbirini saç baş.
Birinin kızı var, birinin oğlu.
Ben bunları biliyorum,
çünkü oradayım 79 tarihinden beri.
Birinin oğlu oldu, birinin kızı;
biri sindirmeyi öğrendi, biri sinmeyi.
Biri şiddet uygulamayı öğrendi,
biri de susmayı öğrendi.
Haa, o zaman neymiş;
biz çocuklarımızın yanında,
davranışlarımıza dikkat etmeliyiz.
Bu çok önemli.
Biz çocuklarımıza,
tepesine vura vura, ''sen sigara içme.''
Hayır, biz içmeyeceğiz.
''Kitap oku.''
Hayır, biz okuyacağız.
Çünkü benim de üç tane evladım var.
Ben çocuklarıma asla demedim,
ama örnek oldum,
çünkü çocuklar bizleri örnek alır.
Velhasılıkelam,
''Yün Bebek'' filmini de çektim, şimdi ben
çok, oradan oraya giderim o kadar çok ki.
''Yün Bebek'' filmini de çektik,
tabii ki hiç öyle kolay olmadı.
3 metre karda çektik.
Bir sürü insanlar destek verdi bize;
bir kere Mersin'deki kurumlar, valilik,
belediyeler, bir sürü.
Hangi birini sayayım,
bir sürü insanın emeği var orada.
Ve ödül aldık.
Şimdi bana yazar, yönetmen, oyuncu
şu bu, bir sürü unvan taktılar.
Ama ben sadece ve sadece anneyim,
bu unvan bana yetiyor.
Bunu gururla söylüyorum,
çünkü ben 38 yıllık mutlu, evli,
3 çocuk annesi bir anneyim.
Diğerleri bana vız gelir tırıs gider.
İsterim ki bütün anneler öyle olsun.
Teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkış)